- People tell me that New York
can be the best place in the world;
the most social place in the world.
But it can also be the loneliest place
in the world as well.
The goal of the supper club
is to bring people together.
(orchestral music)
My name is Vincent Woo,
and I am known for running
a supper club called
Mr. Jones Supper Club.
Yeah, I'm gonna get the scallops.
In the basement of my apartment.
Chives.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And a small basket of the shallots.
It started when I got here
about three years ago.
I didn't know anyone and
I missed getting together
around the kitchen with
friends and eating.
So I started with acquaintances,
and then one thing led to another
and it sort of blew up.
I only do it two times a month.
But the demand is over
two three years now.
And that's rounding down.
Guests do not have to pay to come.
You pay whatever you feel
like at the end of the night,
based on how much they
enjoyed the experience
and how much they can afford.
I'm not formally trained in cooking.
Let's say YouTube is probably my teacher.
Every month in Mr. Jones,
no menu is ever the same.
Last Saturday we started
off with some burrata,
and then it was accompanied by tuna tartar
and topped with fried lotus root chips.
Then we had scallop crudo.
It also had a lot of
Asian flavors as well.
Then we had the mushroom
on mushroom on mushroom,
which is like big chunky
maitake mushroom baked in the oven.
I love doing this.
I definitely have made friends from it.
People have definitely made friends
with each other from it as well.
My first time like, you know,
finding long lost people together.
- [Woman] Exactly.
- [Vincent] I think it's
a good way just to stop
and get people to be present sometimes
with people without phones and just talk
and get to know someone.
(orchestral music)